welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and it looks
like the upcoming x-men MCU movie could
have a big new take on some of the key
characters in the franchise the story
which broke this morning and has already
picked up a lot of traction on the
internet with the trending at second
place on Twitter in the UK states that
Kevin Feige and the creative team at
Marvel Studios are considering people of
color for both Magneto and Professor X
as you can imagine the internet took
this really well and there wasn't any
hour oh wait so yeah there's been a lot
of backlash to the entire thing with
people saying that they thought that the
recasting would lead to a Jewish actor
finally getting the part after having
been portrayed by Ian McKellen and
Michael Fassbender so far the
counter-argument to this is that both
Magneto and Professor X are based on
Martin Luther King and Malcolm X and
that due to the second world war most
notably the Holocaust which is tied to
Magneto's origin story that this simply
happened far too long ago for the
character to be up and about at this
point by the time the film finally gets
made the character would be over a
hundred years old so you can see why
they are trying to rework things to show
him differently Professor X's origin
isn't massively change with the
characters simply being part of an
affluent family but you can see why
Marvel are wishing to distance
themselves from prior incarnations most
notably the Fox franchise after Dark
Phoenix failed to deliver both
critically and financially Kevin Feige
earlier this year said that
representation and the MCU is important
and how going forward he wants a film
franchise that reflects the world as it
is today still though it seems like many
Ora know that the character who is
Jewish in the majority of incarnations
has been sidelined for a new version
let's go over some tweets from both
sides of the argument so you can form
your own opinion on things a trois a
Dylan says if you annoyed at Marvel
Studios potentially looking to guess POC
to play Magneto and Professor X you're
really going to get fired up when you
learn what inspired the creation of the
x-men in the first place agent Fitz 777
tweeted okay two things one I am fine
with this as long as magneto is still
Jewish - could we also just Center the
x-men around some of the x-men's Canon
PLC specifically storm whereas it Jeremy
or thirteen says the MCU is looking at
finding people of color to play
Professor X and Magneto
Lord Feige said diversity makes stories
better I feel better stories make the
stories better am I the only one that
thinks Marvel is taking this pitch too
far magneto was a Holocaust survivor and
Chris was here three to one with my
favorite one of the entire thing magneto
is going to go from Holocaust survivor
to a fired stock employee finally Jewish
speed says as long as magneto is played
by a Jewish actor and his Jewish
identity isn't grazed I don't care I
think that's the main argument in
everything with its seeming like Disney
is negating one race in order to put
another one in but personally I think as
long as the storyline is there and it's
done in the correct manner that this
could work
if Will Smith and idris elba get cast as
Professor X and Magneto I'd be over the
moon but I do get why people are annoyed
at the change this time as it seems tied
to the character's origin that he's a
Polish Jew which looking back were
predominantly not people of color it's a
tricky one but these guys are just
fictional characters at the end of the
day so they can be whatever the writer
needs them to be
I think it's par for the course so that
the internet gets annoyed about this and
it often brings up the race swapping
debate of why new POC characters can't
just be made instead of taking old white
ones and swapping them out does it make
a character better if they used to be
white and then got swapped out or is it
better to have a new one created
specifically for this we likely will
never have a concrete answer but I'm
just so glad that the wheels are a
motion on the x-men movie and I think
that it's smart and marbled are using
this opportunity to try something
different
if Magneto and Professor X are a
minority race it could demonstrate both
are thinking of Malcolm X and Martin
Luther King and it would hold a lot more
weight to it especially with the racism
that is currently prevalent throughout
society at the moment with there being
several mass shootings against people
based purely on the color of their skin
the best thing I think that they could
do would be to cast magneto is a POC and
Professor X as a white guy as it could
even showcase how the mutant from a
certain race is labeled a hero whereas
the other is label
threat the films could demonstrate one
side of thinking which is that we need
to divide whereas the other side of the
coin could be represented with the other
perspective it certainly will be
interesting to see and I'm quite excited
to see how Marvel handle this going
forward I'll of course keep you up to
date with all of the news as we have it
but till then I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the situation and what side
of the argument you fall on
I'm sure the comments section on this
video will have a lot to offer so make
sure you leave your thoughts below and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the new room it's sony
disney deal which you'll be linked at
the end I go over everything you need to
know about it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just wanna let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on this
casting in the comment section below
the woman will be chosen at random on
October the 10th and the blue arrow will
be shipped out from then whoever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition eating the best in
us
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]